it's like having a real stuffed animal
come to life because they're huge and
fuzzy and furry and small and you can
pick them up and hold them slinky
curious intelligent and fun-loving Eretz
have been domesticated and bonding with
their owners for centuries but in
modern-day DC New York City Hawaii and
California it's illegal to keep a ferret
as a pet in New York City they've been
labeled as prone to vicious and
unprovoked attacks on humans and when a
ferret owner is caught in the Golden
State they face a $1,000 fine and up to
six months in jail authorities also
confiscate the ferret and send it to an
animal shelter in a neighboring state
it's like a Humphrey Bogart movie they
literally meet at the border and
transfer the ferret you know or like
East Berlin or something sounds
ridiculous but to California's Fish and
Game it's for a purpose there's a great
deal of risk involved with owning
ferrets because they can't escape or go
into the natural environment and kill
some of our more sensitive species Nancy
Wilson has run a non-profit ferret
shelter since 1999 if you did let a fair
and outside or they do escape they can't
survive because they are domesticated if
they did catch something as a mouse or
whatever they wouldn't know to eat it
according to legalise ferret orgs
environmental impact report it appears
improbable that domestic ferrets could
establish a feral colony in California
and no state could provide evidence of
roaming bands of wild ferrets but our
owners say from their ferrets vicious
unprovoked attacks ferrets are no more
and are in most cases less of a danger
to human beings than dogs and cats are
California's Department of Health
Service has counted 452 attacks over a
10-year period yet California's own
research bureau notes that after
adjusting for population dogs are more
likely to bite than ferrets people look
at ferrets as if they're rodents mm-hm
and then the thought of being bitten by
one it's just for some reason for people
scarier than the thought of being bitten
by a cat or dog because people are
bitten by cats and dogs every day like
any pet it all depends on how they're
trained but it's very easy to do and if
you do it properly and interact with
your ferret in a way that they're not
frightened
you would never flick a ferret you would
sheikha ferret disproving regulators
that ferrets don't pose an unusual risk
to biting or going feral is easy but
getting them legal has been an uphill
battle in 2004 California came close
with a bill to decriminalize ferret
ownership Arnold Schwarzenegger didn't
care the state legislature passed the
bill he veto even with the setback
individuals and groups such as legalized
ferrets org and the American ferret
Association will continue to push for
ferret legalization in California as it
takes people grassroots and knocking on
the door of a legislature saying stop
laughs and this issue is important to me
I'm your constituent